forza ragazzi e benvenuti questo sono
eccitato come una pigna caduta
dall'albero in primavera ma per questo
c'è un motivo perché siamo su computing
gelmi che l'italia significa completa la
missione siamo all'episodio andando file
di harry stickman e dell'ultimo episodio
che non ho mai giocato se gli altri li
avevo già giocati in perché avevo già
fatto le versioni sul web e l'avevano
rifatte con aggiunte che stava proprio
non esisteva c'è solo per chi compra il
gioco su steam ed è il finale di harry
stickman quindi let's go my brothers il
finale si genera in base alle scelte che
hai fatto negli altri episodi quali sono
alleato con l ho rubato il diamante di
infiltrati in dieci poche quindi ho
fatto queste due cose qua vediamo che
cosa mi genera se scelgo se due cose
let's go sono sono troppo gasato perché
c'è le altre più o meno sapevo come
andavano anche saranno aggiunto cose
nuove ma questo ragazzo completo da zero
c'è solo tra poco il tetto di sta roba
c'è la giungla
che è successo due flash siamo noi siamo
scappati la fine completa hai già
sentito le top ansimi ci sono alleato
nelle inflitte in dieci per certo che
bisogna sembrava quando guido quella
siamo schiantati su una macchina va bene
devo scegliere un oggetto a testa va
bene allora ali no
lpga controller che controllo rpg come
controller nova insegna ci hanno sparato
in faccia non fa bene se nichi tavolo di
metal gear non so se vedere se questa ma
che parla file questa una città
incredibile facciamo controller con le
ali prova a controllare reali non so
bene nice suscitata sbagliarli tutti il
genio non ce n'è uno giusto aveva molti
sempre anche in russia morti
ok va bene ci hanno beccato la tipa
cacchio scappa harry time machine torni
indietro con la madonna quanto radio ha
fatto bene questo episodio
questo è il primo mese di allenamento si
sono picchiati a vicenda
li hanno buttati fuori all'esercito
chisso buttati vicenda sull'unione
lancio di sassi
adesso qui non si sono più affollati 9
geniale sta roba
se così è geniale non c'è nessuno perché
non si sono più arroganti vabbè vabbè
ragazze st tarantino anzi christopher
nolan e ieri girl e on the bridge non è
stata volete andare io aiuto cosa ha
ficcato funzionato non sono sul mercato
funzionato ma questi saperi diffidati 10
poiché i top club fanno proprio che
vorrei fatto il diamante ciao è bello ma
comunque lui e rubini flynn the complex
versus i filtri di dieci già che charles
chao just prova entrare nell'elite 8
richards si può paradis parali che ne so
e c'è una roba ma no the wall scegliere
ma no non fare niente per non fare
niente
ma cosa ragazzi
raga
non credo che un coltello riesca a
trattenere forse sì ma siamo vivi vera
me ma come nello spazio ma cosa
normalmente tutto esiste essere
all'interno di un razzo
questo l'ho studiato in fisica c'è la
scritta proprio e governiamo con charles
e charles vecchio buttiamo fuori di joe
coraggio va bene alla madonna
abbiamo distrutto
ho fatto un casino però va bene mission
con frey può dire che abbiamo finito
ammissione ok l'aveva fatta let's go
ragazzi erano abbastanza semplice questo
allora ragazzi proviamo invece a usare
il cappello tradito il governo e sono
scappato la field complex ficcando la
mia morte non ho mai conosciuto ed i
meccanismi per questo questo tentativo
vediamo cosa succede che se tutte le
cose che sono successe per arrivare a
questo questa intro siamo in terra del
russia perché come sono scappato da
fineco pertini sono ancora in russia
anche questi sono quelli di prima che
saluto ha visto nel tempo va bene fanno
partendo per andare alla base segreta e
nella giungla e c'è qualcuno che stava
ascoltando che sono io camuffato figuro
66 beh che si è aggrappato
all'elicottero va bene ma se tre ore
dopo la e la madonna
ok mi ha buttato giù va bene sembra
metal gear ragazzi sembra una missione
tal di aaron ground zero
c'è un cecchino naif duplicato range
duplicatore già vip sa cos'è è
bellissimo nostro morto hanno solo io
ero l'altro che siamo davanti un no
hanno ammazzato con il giusto invece ma
come sta la coppia questa hanno sparato
allegri original brodu flick non potevo
che non cliccare duplicatore invece la
g's ricerche qualcosa che ti fa la gare
va bene
sì mi lega spara in realtà non sono lì
perché stola gandosso centrali
ecco è facile no stavo allagando zio va
bene c'è un carro armato enorme di tutto
questo wolf 9 shearer su youtube
avete tutorial siccome si attiva st
arrivare ma cos'è è un walk through su
youtube ma basta quanto 2a sta roba ad
hoc dovevo cliccare un ci credo kleber
che cos'è uno sturalavandini così non ho
capito niente
mi sa che ho sbagliato non lo so si
chiama big boy questo affare
a quanto pare c'è un nome abbastanza
seccato salve sono non sono morto era
giusto ok ammessi sono quelli che
tentano di mettere tutto in tranquillità
quando succede qualcosa che non lo fanno
mai in realtà per ok a ciò varie scelte
ok di un atto di via secret seriously do
not the snapping e molti versi in
valence ok andiamo su questo che non
sono la sia
ce la si è incazzata la luna c'è la luna
incazzata va bene sono è un po esagerare
un po esagerato
uno sarà giusto lounging a bag questo è
un gaber sarà una città che non sto
togliendo a partito rock e rock it link
diventato ma raga ma mi ha cacciato il
gioco ma cosa ok ragazzi facciamo che
abbiamo rubato il rubino abbandonato
elli e non mi hanno beccato ok non ho
capito cosa cestinata non lo so
l'inglese così bene ma chi se ne frega
no sono io
al naso ed henry spiegare ha sentito la
van delle robe e adesso ne vado uff
mosquito bond cosa ho fatto non lo so ho
cercato a caso sono entrato nella nella
banale strozzare con una zanzara ottimo
devo andare a rubare la roba default nel
bolt sta roba ok è la madonna che le
porte per certe le porte scelte le porte
che non funziona mai teleport tra
l'altro inutile clip provarli pare non
ha funzionato
jan fabre forma guardaroba c'è ragazzi 8
e non ne funziona uno catapult basta
secondo me il tele porter solo perché
non ha mai funzionato e quali hanno
fatto funzionare perché siamo sul finale
scommettete ma dai
per una volta che non l'ho usato l'ho
sempre usato tutte le porte non
funzionava mai guarda anche lui non sa
se usarlo meno e loro 8 minchia oddio
bellissimo cosa è stato bellissimo altra
cosa sta rivestendo pure va beh eccoci
c'è una cacca d'oro ha funzionato tutto
ragazzi open contro il tempo la stella
di mario è bellissimo
mi chiamo ngas c'è il poster ha
funzionato e labbra mite open
eccone i fasti civile sono proprio io
urla porca vacca minchia funzionato la
che non ci credo devo urlare
semplicemente ce l'ho fatta in cui
spider ci credo d'aver protesi sono
volteggiante nello spazio ora che è
stato bello a ok ha perso ancora capire
era giusto fare questa roba loden 6 eric
roy drink rovesci che quello che
diluisce la
porca allora pensavo mi diminuisce
la grandezza me invece dia un messaggio
che è successo mi scusi madonna quanto
gli ho rotto le balle a sti tizi la
mission completare che stavolta sono in
una scatoletta di tonno avere ragazzi
questo era il finale di harry stickman
visto che l'ultimo episodio non so che
scontro conti piano ci sono se come la
decina perché ci sono un sacco di cose
che puoi abbinare all'inizio ma siccome
ce ne sono così tante farò sicuramente
non altro bisogna ri stigma e quindi
ragazzi c'è la prosecuzione di artisti e
band che non è il finale finale questo è
solo una parte dei finali sono molto
care bellissima quest'ultima parte
veramente lunghissima la bellissima per
avere sia piaciuto nel frattempo ragazzi
possono dire non mi piace anche vari
social quindi data la schizzare se non
so che ci siete vi e noi come sempre se
però il telecomando ragazzo sta ora qua
prima telecomando da qui io questo lo
uso al 2013 ancora non lo trovo bello ci
ha proseguito beh ragazzi
[Musica]